what up guys welcome to the jazz pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
brennie lee stop chasing him he's not
the one i saw this video guys
oh my gosh i've never seen such bad
advice i've never seen such bad advice
okay before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring the
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
um
also if you hear any like
panting
and stuff in the background that's my
dogs they're like
chilling this week anyways
do not chase a guy that pulls back do
not chase a guy
that is not chasing you why because
faith doesn't worry and value doesn't
beg value does not bear to be seen value
is what it is if someone sees you as
valuable they will put in the work
hey guys welcome back to my channel hope
you guys are doing well i'm going to
start off by saying my voice is a little
bit raspy i've literally been sick for
about a week and a half my hey
of my voice being like this but it's a
little bit raspy but you guys will be
able to understand me and listen and
hear me clearly so this is day one of my
video series of revenge okay seven days
of revenge actually when i call it okay
back to basics series this is gonna be
seven days of taking us back to basics
because some of us are coming out of
relationships some of us have been in
the market and just don't know how to
navigate things it's not refreshing of
the three years four years five years
i've been on youtube talking to you guys
about relationships and stuff like this
i know a lot of you guys are just fresh
out of relationships and you've kind of
forgotten the rules of engagement so
today's video we're going to be talking
about do not under any circumstance i
mean ever ever ever in your life pursue
a man never ever ever chase a man and
some of you may be thinking yeah it's a
no-brainer but in today it's not a
no-brainer
is it brony brainy bunny
that's not true
oh my gosh okay let me let me tell you
guys a story okay
stop it dot
i have
three brothers okay
they all
one of them is only 21 but i guarantee
he'll be making six figures in five
years my older two brothers
are at six figures or higher
my oldest brother is married
and let me be clear that woman chased
him
she chased him
my next brother she waited
maybe longer than she should have but
she got the ring right she followed him
for his job
where he wanted to be
um then we have my next brother austin
he stop it
he has a girlfriend of
i don't know two three years
um and let me tell you
when he got a job in utah do you know
what she did
she packed up her [ __ ] and got a job in
utah guarantee that girl will get a ring
whenever she wants it
my brother's cheap right like
she's gonna have to twist his arm a
little bit you'd have to
know my brother to understand but she'll
get a ring he'll he'll be with her
literally for as long as she wants to be
with him
ladies sometimes chasing a man isn't a
bad thing
like why is this
so sought after my boyfriend right
super successful guy
i chased him
100 chased him
and now i have him
like
today's video i'm gonna break it down
for you so let's get right into it okay
i will disagree because this is bad
advice oh my gosh
i was watching this video yesterday and
i was going to so now why i don't
believe that a woman should make the
first move contrary to popular belief i
don't think the woman should make the
first move i don't think a woman should
hunt pursue
chase a man and here's a number one
reason why if you were to chase a guy
make the first move shoot your shot
whatever you want to call it you're the
one approaching this person saying let's
make it happen and by the way i have
done a video on how to shoot your shot
and so this does not contradict what i
said in the video because there's a
difference between making yourself
available making yourself accessible and
actually shooting your shot going on
instagram and liking a few photos is not
you shooting your shot that's you saying
hello hi it's me and trying to get that
person's attention okay it's also the
same as putting yourself okay i hate
men like women that like them
and aren't afraid to show it
this is the thing like sometimes as
girls i think we internalize like what
we like and think men are like that men
aren't like us
they're not like us it's not like
you can over
like if we have a guy that shows us too
much interest we get turned off
men aren't like that they like girls
that are interested in a facility of men
and it's also the same as going on
dating apps which is in my opinion not
you shooting your shot or pursuing a man
you're just making yourself available so
i am not against that and do not
misconstrue what i am saying there's a
difference between making yourself
accessible available and actually making
the first move if you're making yourself
available at a bar let's say you're
hanging out by the bar you're looking
good you're looking cute or whatever
that's the difference between you
actually going up to a guy that you like
then you sit in there and waiting for a
guy to come to you i'll just say for me
for instance i'm on hinge yeah and if
you know how hinge works you obviously
like you swipe you like you see who you
like or whatever but there's also a like
section on the hinge app and in that
section is the people that have liked
you i don't actually go on the main page
and swipe unlike anyone i choose from
the people that like me and i like them
back okay so that's one of the ways i've
put myself out there yes but at the same
time i'm not the one making the first
guys don't like these games ladies like
they don't they don't like these games
and
a guy isn't going to care if you make
the first move or you don't
if he likes you he likes you
like he knew matt like j-lo made the
first move with
a-rod and that man's literally obsessed
with her
like
this is the number one reason why you
should not make the first move and the
number one reason why you should not
pursue a man because okay even if you
get the guy even if you get his
attention even if you get his number
even if you get his interest you will
actually never know if he would have
chosen you if you didn't you will
actually well who cares if you got him
who cares i don't know what he
really wanted to
do
you also don't know if he just wouldn't
have noticed you like there's a million
girls out there like there's so many
females
like
how the hell is this man supposed to
know that you're special
if he doesn't know you at all do you
know how many pretty females there are
like literally so many quick example
okay you know sometimes you're out and
you're vibing with someone like girl guy
whatever you're out you're vibing with
someone and everyone's like oh we should
share instagrams yeah awkwardly we
should share instagram oh hey what's
your instagram i always feel really
uncomfortable when someone's like hey
what's your instagram because it almost
feels like i'm obliged to follow them
back and so let's say in the right
instances where i do follow someone back
i sometimes will scroll past their
content because i didn't actually choose
you i didn't actually want to add you i
kind of feel pressured into accepting
your request it's kind of the same with
guys and a lot of guys they don't
necessarily like to reject girls
especially not in person okay so he's
not necessarily going to say actually no
some guys may but most guys aren't going
to say no so you're actually never
really going to know if this guy would
have approached you if you didn't
approach him and okay let's let's say
it's the worst right let's say
he wouldn't have approached you if you
didn't approach him
but you approach him he likes what he
sees
you got his attention
stop sorry my dog is so annoying um you
got his attention
and maybe you're not the prettiest girl
he's ever dated or whatever
but
you show him your value with
cooking cleaning or whatever whatever
matters to him right
is that
like
who cares if that's the way it happens
like i don't know why females are so
obsessed with like oh he's gotta chase
me i have like i am the prize
like girl there's you know how many
pretty females there are get off your
high horse go chase after a man that's
worth chasing
i don't know about you guys but i
believe that men are hunters men go
after what they want they are the
pursuers in this and whether you like it
or not whether you're like okay oh god
guys okay i grew up with these men
you don't have to believe me i grew up
with these guys
that that are making a lot of money that
are successful
i've talked to my brothers about this
i've talked to my dad about this
all of their significant others chased
them
who cares if you're gonna get the ring
who cares
well we gotta mix it up it's 20 21
that's old school blah blah blah it
isn't a man's dna to go after what he
wants i was actually speaking to my
friend the other day and he was
basically telling me that he went after
what he wanted in the relationship with
a girl it didn't work out but he's so
happy that he went after
what he wanted men rarely settle because
they are always the ones choosing
someone okay and so no men settle all
the time
men literally settle all the time men
are not like us women don't settle
men do
men do i'm sorry
men fall in love through loyalty and
quality time
both of those things take time to show
and you know how you can see this ladies
eighty percent of divorces are filed by
women
men are not the ones leaving
relationships
i'm sorry they're just not so i say that
to say it isn't a man's dna to hunt is
an immensely named approach is in a
man's dna to actually pursue someone so
that was me talking about in the initial
stages of meeting someone i don't think
you should be the one to be like oh hey
boys
hey so like
like i feel like the most feminine thing
that you can do is play your position
put yourself out there but you're not
the one to first go and approach the
person like i said men are hunters and
men go after what they want if you
approach a man first you will never ever
know if that's what he wanted to do so
who cares
guys men aren't like us they're not
gonna entertain you
especially if you're not sleeping with
them they're not going to entertain you
if you don't like them
oh my gosh okay i'm going to take away
his power you take away his masculinity
you take away his ability to be the one
to pursue to make the first move when
you make the first move okay so that's
me talking about the initial attraction
okay let's say he made the first move
yeah it's the same thing applying
there's a lot of times when we can start
talking to someone and they may have
chased you or pursued you all the time
and all of a sudden you find yourself
reversing and chasing them and it kind
of gets like a a weird little situation
a guy will chase you he pulls back and
then you're so used to him chasing you
that you're like hold on a second what's
going on here a lot of these games would
be avoided if women dated intentionally
so if you said from the get-go i'm
looking to get married
from the get-go
like a lot of these issues of like
chasing pursuing who's chasing who like
these games are tiring ladies
who cares who cares who's chasing who
as long as you're both in it and
interested like i'm not saying chase a
man that's ghosting you
but
like there's a million pretty females
out there sometimes you have to prove
that you're different
men can't magically
know
just from meeting you
see you across the bar and know that you
have a lot to offer like
men aren't like us and you start chasing
him back and then it becomes a woman
then pursuing a relationship with a man
let's say you guys are in a talking
stage you guys are talking to each other
again to know each other and he kind of
pulls back do not chase a guy that pulls
back do not chase a guy that is not
chasing you and i don't even have to use
the word chase i believe hunted is the
correct word you have to be pursued okay
and what does being pursued look like it
looks like constant communication that
calls texas on a daily basis that is
going out on dates netflix and children
count going for drinks all the time does
not count him coming to your place all
the time does not count you need to be
pursued like you're the person that why
i hate to break it to you oh my gosh i'm
just thinking about my brothers a lot of
these guys that are making the type of
money that women want are cheap
ladies
they're not taking anyone on nice dates
you know how often my brother takes his
girlfriend in a nice state not often
he's damn near in love with the girl
that's gonna be the mother of his kids
[Music]
but
as girls we need to stop taking things
so personally
i'm not saying
to let a guy treat you like absolute
trash
but a date like once a month twice a
month
what's so wrong with that you don't have
to
you guys can do casual stuff it's not
like you're getting to know each other
why does it have to be
like
fancy restaurants and like
it's like the entitlement like he's
paying for your drinks but that doesn't
count like okay
he wants and that's why we talk about
women being the prize because in that
instance
a guy is supposed to win you over and if
he's not winning you over he's acting
all lackluster and casual and reserved
about it it is only normal that we will
be like okay what's going on maybe i
need to take it up a notch and i feel
like a lot of women always think okay if
something's not happening then maybe
it's to do with me maybe i need to be
the one doing it maybe i need to be the
one texting him first in the morning
maybe i need to be the one calling him
first maybe i need to be the one
planning this no you don't but a guy
really really really really really
really really really likes you you're
not gonna have to ask him to do the bare
minimum if you have to ladies be honest
do we typically like the guys that
really really really really really
really like us
britney briny
how many guys are in your friend zone
how many guys are in your friend zone
answer the question like
so after that after the bare minimum cut
it out it's a wrap and this is why it's
so important that when you're dating
someone that you take your time okay i
know you like him i know he's cute i
know he started off well
i agree with this take your time getting
to know someone i i agree with this i
know you guys feel like you have amazing
an amazing connection amazing chemistry
but if you feel that way then you should
be able to take your time you
rushing it is not going to make it go
better it's actually going to make it
worse you actually need to be like okay
i had a great date with this guy i
really really really like this person
but i'm going to wait for him to call me
first i'm going to wait for him to text
me first i'm going to wait for him to
plan you realize some guys
wait to see if the girls interested
ladies put yourself out there let him
know that you like him don't play these
games let him know
and see what he does
if you let him know that he likes you
or that you like him
and he doesn't set up another date okay
he's not that interested like
men are not like us
i'm not gonna drop any hints i'm gonna
let him do what he needs to do and
pursue me in this situation if a guy is
not calling you communicating with you
texting you wanting to know how you're
doing is concerned about your well-being
wants to know how your day's been
doesn't have to be a long conversation
but he's checking in on you that guy is
someone that actually likes you oh my
gosh men don't want to know how our day
is
they don't men
they don't like to talk ladies
if someone's giving you odd messages
like he doesn't takes you back until
four hours later the next day it's dead
like like let it go let it die and we
need to be quick to let things go and
let them die but you also need to slow
down with catching feelings infatuation
sometimes feels like love what will show
you and what will tell you that it is
truly love is time so give the
relationship time give the situation
time let it manifest itself let you see
who he really is because it's so easy to
fall in love with the idea and the first
talking stages the first day even more
times when on the first date with
someone already planning what our
children would look like we're already
planning our wedding you're doing what
but your children will look like oh my
god lady today what are you planning
what dress we're gonna have slow the
hell down relax like it's not that
serious it's not serious until he makes
it serious
period a lot of us women we fall in love
too quickly we fall in like too quickly
and it's really just like why are you
rushing it what are you trying to escape
are you trying to escape being lonely
are you trying to escape your past are
you trying to escape the feelings that
you're feeling why rush things this is
why it's so important to be content in
yourself and by yourself because when
you're content in yourself you know what
you're worth you know your value you
know what you have to offer you're not
selling yourself you're actually not
really promoting yourself to be honest
okay can we just be honest
not every girl has everything has
anything to oh wait let me say it again
not every girl has anything to offer
some girls have literally nothing to
offer i'm like
just like some men have literally
nothing to offer like it goes both ways
you don't have to promise yourself think
about it like this have you ever seen
louis vuitton genuine louis vuitton bags
a representative from louis vuitton on
the street corner begging people to buy
their bags or handing out flies have you
ever been oh my god you can't snap your
fingers and magically make yourself
louis vuitton
ladies no you're lame okay if you're an
8 9 or 10
sure in looks right if you're an 8 9 or
10 and you're young
sure
but i'm sorry ladies
some of y'all
are discount bags and that's okay
it doesn't mean you're not valuable it
doesn't mean you're not worthy it
doesn't mean
but
you guys can't all snap your fingers and
magically be louis vuittons that's okay
that's okay
oh my god
lutherton doesn't advertise themselves
unless it's in vogue unless it's in
gracias luxury magazines the magazines
and publications that people actually
read that actually have money to
actually buy and you're not going to see
them advertising on on a bus you're not
going to see them handing out flyers why
because faith doesn't worry and value
doesn't beg value does not beg to be
seen value does not beg to be seen value
is what it is if someone sees you as
valuable they will put in the work if
he's not put but men can't magically
just know that you're valuable like
ladies you have to prove it to him and
i'm sorry like especially the older you
get like
because men start to think why is she
still single
why has if she's so valuable why hasn't
someone swooped up and like bought her
like that that's how men think
i'm not saying it's fair i'm not saying
it's right i'm not even saying it's okay
i'm just saying it is what it is and
telling girls don't chase him your louis
vuitton like
such bad advice putting in the work let
it go and let the infatuation go let the
dream go okay a guy is constantly
showing you what he thinks of you if
he's inconsistent
take it that he's not that serious or
he's probably dating somebody else and
the first date may be fine first few
days maybe you're fine you guys may have
had an amazing connection but all of a
sudden things are starting to slow down
and you're asking yourself well what did
i do wrong is there anything that i
could have done better is it me maybe
i'm this or maybe i'm not maybe i'm
missed whatever whatever actually no if
a guy felt the same way that you felt
about those dates you'll be hearing from
him because you have to kind of ask
yourself what would i do when i like
someone what do i do
if he's not doing what you would do
right they need to like you that's how
simple it is when i like someone no
because men are different than women
when they calling me i'm like hey
i'm answering the phone straight away
i'm texting back i'm double texting i'm
making sure that they know that i'm good
i'm making sure that they know that i'm
here i'm available that i like them i'm
sending them compliments i'm messaging
on instagram i'm sending them memes like
if i like you then i'm gonna act like it
if a guy's not acting nothing like she
probably doesn't and we really need to
allow ourselves to be hunted okay this
is you guys this challenge okay and i
remember i said it's one of my guy
friends says him like i just want to be
hunted do you know what he said to me he
said if you want to be haunted don't be
an easy catch hey i almost ah
i was trying to act like oh yeah
obviously i'm not going to be an easy
catch in that obviously i'm not going to
be an easy catch in that well i was like
oh he really said that and that's for
you too if you want to be haunted don't
be an easy catch even when he's hunting
do you know why he said that
he likes you
he likes you
he doesn't
want you to be easily caught by other
dudes
you think if that guy friend had a girl
that was really interested in him oh my
gosh oh stop really liked him
and communicated that that he would
he wouldn't be interested you know when
he's haunting you and even when he's
pursuing you don't be so readily
available don't be so easy accessible
don't make it easy
do not make it easy i mean don't make it
hard either or necessarily hard but
don't make it easy don't be an easy cat
have a life be busy be about your
business focus on you still when a guy
comes along don't change your focus okay
yeah that's that's what guys want they
want girls that are busy
look at my face
i don't know what you're focusing on and
let him come stand beside you don't
change your focus when somebody comes
along that's where a lot of women go
wrong and that's what i want to talk
about as well don't put a guy before you
especially when you're dating even when
you're engaged when you're married maybe
it's a different ballgame but don't have
anyone before you because after that guy
goes ghost or you don't hear from him or
you put all your hopes in your dreams
and all your eggs in one basket now
you're feeling like broken now you're
like who am i you feel lost why because
you're putting this other anything worth
having
anything worth having comes with the
risk of being hurt
guys don't like girls that are
entertaining a million guys so they
don't get hurt
i'm sorry they don't like that find a
guy that is worth chasing
choose wisely find a guy that's worth
chasing
person in front of you don't put anyone
else before you you're valuable your
time is valuable your life is precious
too don't put anyone before you and
going back to being hunted right there's
a difference between being hunted and
being chased anything that you chase
will run away you don't want to be
chased okay you want to be haunted you
want to be pursued a hunter will go out
with an intention i'm going to catch
that deer i'm going to catch whatever
animals that they hunt for they go out
they leave their house early in the
morning they've got their equipment
they've got their boots they're hiking
they're searching oh my god they're
searching for hours and hours and hours
and hours and then when they spot it
when they spot that deer when they spot
what they're looking for they are going
after it right you don't have to
question whether a guy likes you you'll
feel it
you'll feel the pursuit even so much
he'd be calling you like bro can i get a
minute and then get a second if he's
inconsistent he's not texting you back
like if he's like got excuses every time
you message him it's dead let it die let
it go and any man that won't hunt you
doesn't deserve you and i mean that in
the most humblest way like a man that
won't hunt you doesn't deserve it do you
think guys working 80 90 hours a week
have time to hunt you
do you think you're that special
easy clearly got too many options or so
he thinks and so men go after what they
want and if they're not going after you
it means that they don't really want you
or they're not sure which is still the
same as no it's just gotta be like yes
or no no i'm not sure also don't get
swayed by oh i'm not ready to be in a
relationship
that's the one piece of good advice if a
guy says he's not ready for a
relationship
i would say
don't waste your time like find a guy
that's marriage minded if you want to
get married
you don't let any guy leave you in a
gray zone you need to know what it is
and he needs to keep it real and keep it
funky and he needs to be allow you he's
not sure he should give you the grace to
make a decision based on his uncertainty
if you don't know
why you're holding on to me if you don't
know
why should i wait around for you to
clear up your brain i don't agree with
waiting on anybody if you can't see me
if you can't see who i am
goodbye or get glasses
here's the thing about making the first
move if you make the first move you're
gonna always be making the first move
you make the first move to approach him
you're gonna make the first move to call
him if you make the first move to call
him you're gonna make the first move to
a candidate when you go on a date you're
gonna make the first move to do a
swallow update if you did a full update
you're always going to be making the
first move if you make the first move
and the problem with that is
okay this is not true
i made the first move with my boyfriend
i made the first move for inviting him
to hang out
he's taken me
to nicer dates than i could ever afford
in my life
like he took me to an nba finals game
who does that
my boyfriend
stop
he's taking me to five star restaurants
like
places
i would never go five-star hotels
and hey hey
and i i had to invest up front not
knowing if there'd be like a return
right
i mean that sounds like a weird way to
put it but
like ladies it's okay to chase after a
guy at first don't do it for years
but
it's okay to let a guy know that you
like him it's okay
to even ask him on a date at first
like ask him to hang out
i'm not saying don't do that for years
don't waste that much time but
like ladies come on
in a feminine submissive position right
and then you turn around months later
and you cannot ask yourself why is that
so passive why doesn't he take
initiative why doesn't he make plans
because you set the relationship up for
you to be the one that wears the pants
okay just imagine this dwayne the rock
johnson
let's say his wife made the first move
do you think
he would just become submissive
like that's not how men are
like you're not gonna magically make a
guy
feminine and submissive just because you
make the first move and he's wearing the
skirt he's wearing the dress okay he is
the one like okay well what do you want
to do i don't know what do you want to
do i mean what i don't know what do you
want you that's not alpha that's not
manly like you want to be with someone
that's going to take initiative and
taking initiative is like okay babe get
ready five o'clock we're going to the
restaurant
like you want to be with someone that's
going to take the lead if you start off
taking the lead you're going to always
take the lead think about it and let's
be honest there are some guys out there
and in the society we're living in now
they don't mind if you take the lead
they don't mind if you make the first
move they don't mind if you propose to
them first because they want to sit back
and chill they want to be a housewife
they just want to be housewives too
like there's guys out here that want to
be kept like and they will they will
they will they will drain you they will
dream you again a guy like that he's
never gonna respect you and you're never
gonna respect him that's just not how it
works and no masculine guy is truly
attracted to an aggressive woman men
don't like aggressive women and no
matter how beautiful you look it's not
about
looks but
okay
there is a way to put yourself out there
and make the first move and still be
feminine like either you're fem you're a
feminine person or you're not
like
oh my gosh the hoops these girls jump
through
like like okay does it make sense if i
say hey like you're cute i like you we
should go on a date sometime
if i say that like i'm kind of my voice
is kind of cracking because
i keep looking for wow
um
like you can say that in a feminine way
look
you can say that kindly sweetly and
feminine
i mean
sure ladies are there going to be guys
that take advantage they know you like
them sure
but like that's that's the thing you
can't
make guys of the future pay for mistakes
of your past you can't say oh well i've
been taken advantage of before so let me
make all the guys in the future pay for
this
now i'll never open up again now i'm
never gonna make the first move again
like
ladies stop like making the first move
puts you in a position to be rejected
and that sucks being rejected like it
sucks it's not fun
but who cares like seriously who cares
swallow your pride go after what you
want
there are beautiful women that are
aggressive as unattractive it's
masculine and it's repulsive like
honestly especially to masculine men
some feminine men that have more
feminine energy they don't mind you
being like
common god they don't mind you making
the first move planning things
living in your house eating your food
what
do you mean like they don't mind that
there's a lot as a new breed of men that
they're looking for women just like that
but let me let you know
lady ladies that if you take the
masculine role you're going to
continuously be playing that role and
one thing a lot of us need to stop doing
is being understanding oh he didn't call
me because he
ah
why do we do this to each other ladies
that's not what a man looks for in a
wife understanding like come on
i had an emergency with
he didn't call me because he was at work
he didn't call me because he was okay
this is this is what you do
like she had an experience for a guy
she was too understanding he took
advantage so now she's saying all men in
the future you will pay like that's not
how it works
start with understanding if they keep
doing the same thing over and over again
okay like he probably doesn't like you
but here's the problem men tell us what
they want we don't listen
most guys will tell you they don't want
a relationship
we don't listen
with his family
he didn't call me because he's so busy
listen
listen
i don't i don't care how busy somebody
is they're gonna have a minute to reply
your message honestly think about it
like this how many guys have you got on
unread oh no what's up imessage in your
dms how many people have you refused to
respond to why because you don't you
ain't feeling them like that they're
trying to make conversation with you but
they're not at the top of your priority
list if somebody's interested in you
the men are like us oh my gosh they're
not like us i'm not saying like a guy
doesn't respond to you for days right or
even
even weeks he's barely interested like
but it also depends on
how much time you've invested in it like
if you've gone on one date you can't exp
expect that much level of interest
like
it's one day
it's gonna be a priority you know what a
lot of us do and i'm gonna make a video
on this shortly is that we make so many
excuses for these men and we give them
the benefit of the doubt stop giving men
the benefit of the doubt no don't don't
listen to that girls give men the
benefit of the doubt
give them give it to them
the truth will come out sooner or later
like it's going to come out eventually
you're going to know if he's interested
like
and quite frankly most men you could
just ask them and they'll tell you
give them the benefit of the doubt don't
don't come into this world jaded
and
bitter
because that's how she comes off she's
jaded and she's bitter because someone
hurt her
so let me make the rest of the man that
i talk to in the future pay for it and
it's going to keep her single just watch
they don't deserve it if it quacks like
a duck if it responds like a dump it's
probably a goddamn duck don't let him
off the hook apply the pressure i don't
mean aggressively if you're not gonna
message me back you know what forget
about it and i'll tell you about a quick
story that i had like a while ago
like a little while ago i was like i
will see this guy and he was like very
fine very cool and he knew it so i loved
really well messaging me seeing me
whatever and then he got really slack he
got really busy but then he would reply
my message is late we're having a full
conversation he'll go quiet reply later
on that evening or the next day the last
time he did that i was like oh hey where
are you at i'm a little cute
or whatever no nudes doesn't look cute
your photo like i was out and then
no reply and then the next morning
telling me a voice note like hey so
yeah i'm so sorry yesterday was like a
super busy day blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah i
hope you're well you look nice as always
blah blah blah blah blah blah then i
listened to the voice note and i just
ignored it and that was a little while
ago
and um today guess who's calling me
guess who's guess who's uh blowing up my
phone him
and i'm i have no interest because i
even told this guy before like what your
communication is garbage is trash like
oh i honestly communicate with you more
than i communicate with anybody else i'm
like if that's your level of consistency
keep it i'm good i've moved on and this
is the thing right ladies when you
cap
girls say this they'll respond later
because she clearly has an interest in
him
like clearly options you're not
desperate okay
what are you doing
sorry sorry about options
[Music]
honestly have options and stop putting
all of your eggs in one basket and even
when you find someone that you like
don't be cutting this might sound a
little bit controversial you meet
someone and you like them and whatever
everything's going good blah blah blah
that's not any reason for you to cut
everybody off sorry until you've made a
commitment until you've made it official
you need to know that i've still got
options and this is not about
anything you're just having conversation
with you maybe even going out on dates a
lot of women they don't know how to date
multiple people like they don't know how
to do it and i can't admit i was
definitely that person i could i don't
have time to be honest i didn't have
time but you need to know that you have
options because when one egg cracks in
that bottom it is always the girls
saying oh i have so many options that
like don't have that many good options
you know you've got one over here one of
them always the girls say oh i don't
have time they usually have time over
here and you've got potential to care
you never want to feel like you don't
have options and you maybe feel like oh
it's easy for you
no honey you've got options you've got
options there's been a thousand dating
apps out there like even putting
yourself on the date and i've actually
bumped into one of the girls and if
you're watching this video hey the other
day and i was just talking about hinge
in my last video and she was like i
downloaded hinge and look at all the
guys in my inbox i was like hey girl i'm
gonna play inspire you but even just to
have guys to talk to doesn't have to be
a date to know that you have options
honestly takes the weight off you and
the pressure of you to be it has to be
this guy oh my gosh this is
okay i'm done i'm done watching this
video i can't take it
ladies stop with the games men don't
like these games
you can't magically snap your fingers
and make yourself a designer bag
sometimes you're gonna have to chase a
guy
let him know you're interested
put yourself out there like that and
possibly get hurt
it happens
but like nothing worth having in life
comes with that risk
every person in my family that married
someone making six figures or more
chased them
sorry
it sucks that's what you got to do let
me know in the comments if you agree or
you disagree
i also don't mean chasing a guy that has
no interest in you but it's okay to be
understanding if a guy doesn't respond
right away it's okay to be understanding
if god doesn't text you first after a
date like stop playing these games
stop it's not cute it's not fun and men
don't like it so